today on our show walls backs never he
never left come on back to us we're
gonna talk about this man Paul he does
comics from time to time and he did the
hell out of this comic this is a real
story we're gonna dive deep into it
right here on this edition get your
tissues and I've got my bullets issues
we're ready for the real fields
hello welcome to fat man I'm Batman I'm
Kevin Smith mark barnard okay over there
Paul Dini still with us here that game I
was sleeping under the under the desk
it's very comfy you want nowhere yeah
except in his career you went everywhere
that that game and just stayed here all
last episode if you haven't seen it go
check it out all we did was cover Paul's
prehistory up until this moment in time
right there this is what we're gonna
throw up that graphic you got yes yep
you see that it's called Dark Knight a
true Batman story written by mr. Paul
Dini himself with art by the amazing
Eduardo risotto this is a vertigo title
yeah it is what was last time Batman was
in a vertigo book I don't think so I
don't think ever maybe last orchid or
something like that absolutely writing
black oh yeah yeah they were normally
for those that you know follow they
don't follow the sort of thing generally
they keep them separate yeah Batman
stays in a TCU and an Oreo stays Murray
go but this is a special occasion Paul
as you heard in the last episode has
rich deep history with Warner Brothers
DC and all the Batman characters
including creating Harley Quinn with
Bruce Timm so Paul's Paul's entrenched
in the universe
and not just the DC Warner Brothers
universe of superheroes and whatnot but
also just everything that you loved as
we heard from the last episode he's been
involved in like from Fat Albert all the
way from he-man he-man
Ewoks and droids and on Mays we're
focused he's worked as Spielberg and
stuff and you hear that and you're like
lucky amazing talented like boy why does
all the good things only
but then into every life a little rain
must fall man and there's in this
instance this is a story of much much
worse than rain and it's a survivor
story this dark night man this came from
a story that Paul told me that like one
of those stories where you hear somebody
tell you like oh that happened in the
movie gonna happen in real life is a
true story and it was harrowing the
harrowing tale which I'm gonna give him
a single and he's going to tell you a
bit about it but like any good artist
he's taken in pain and turned it into
something useful a useful document for
for not just change but also how heavens
men this is a story about survival in
many more ways than the one but you know
what I'm I'm burying the lede
give him a single and tell him what
happened well you know I got a thank you
for Kevin for in the first place first
for me writing this because I remember
it was like three or four years ago
misty and I were on your show with with
Jen and we were talking you know just
sort of chit-chatting and you know and
you're on your the morning show you do
and you came up well tell me about the
mugging
that's like buggin happened a long time
ago and I don't know if you and I had
discussed that before or were people he
knew knew about it or anything and it
was like yeah okay so we started talking
about it and and then when I was done
explaining it you said man if that
happened to me I never would have left
my house and I said oh man come on hell
you wouldn't know you're your film
director you deal with a lot of
responsibility you're out there you've
got a lot of decisions to make you
you've left your house and it's like
well maybe not you know and I was
thinking you know like I dunno people
who have had a traumatic instance in
their life that has sort of defined them
in a certain way either they've risen
above it and they've overcome the
hardship and gone on or else they've
crumbled and or withdrawn and the more I
thought about it the more I was thinking
like maybe that's a story worth putting
down
we're telling about how to how to get
out you know and God knows that a lot of
other people most other people have
dealt with more hardships and I have but
I think everybody has a moment you know
they like that you know that crossroads
mom and of like how do I get through
this how do I go on and I thought okay
well I think it's worth telling and I
and I went into Danielle's office and he
was there with Geoff Johns and we talked
about it and they both you know agreed
you know write it up show it to us dan
really liked the story Geoff liked the
story and I met with them both
separately we discussed it and he
thought Dan thought it would be a really
good story for vertigo because we could
be a little more extreme and take more
chances and also it's a uniqueness of
having Batman in a vertigo story and yet
it's not really a Canon Batman story it
isn't it isn't a Batman story it's um
it's not one that really falls within
the purview of the universe but it deals
with Batman more as an idea and as a
concept and as a character in a writer's
brain and because I've written Batman it
it became like well this is the
extension of myself that I use when I
write Batman and it happened
the incident happened you know what the
incident is about is like I was mugged
one night walking a date home from her
from her car it happened not long not
far from here in fact I was driving up
Wilshire Boulevard I passed Bombay
Palace which was the restaurant I got to
earlier that night so it was right in
the neighborhood I rode at some point I
could tell you to take you right over to
the the street where it happened whoa
and and I was walking home from from the
evening and my thoughts were someplace
else and I see some guys coming down the
street and I keep going and as they
passed me they started making fun of me
like you know just a few steps ahead and
I looked up at them and they just they
left me they they they were they left on
me and they and beat the living [ __ ] out
of me and and it was just you know wrong
place at the wrong time and and wasn't
like it was the neighborhood would you
even expect it it's not like I was
walking downtown you were just walking
like Beverly Hills right yeah yeah and
it was like it was very close to my
house was two blocks away and there are
two blocks from your house yeah
there are a lot of artists and writers
and and athletes who live in the
neighborhood so these guys look just
like anybody else they would have seen
it the market or anyplace else and and I
just thought yeah a couple of neighbors
and then they just you know cracked me
so so you crawl home after that how do
you you didn't and you lived through it
obviously but I mean in the moment yeah
we've talked about this and it's in the
book yeah there were moments where you
thought that was the moment yeah I mean
clearly they told me it was the moment
it's like we have a gun we're gonna
shoot you we're gonna you know wait you
know close your eyes wait for it and it
was like okay at that moment there was a
weird moment of clarity like you know
say your prayers were habit you know
it's like okay and but it was you know I
don't mean to be that cavalier about it
be it was almost like a whiteout it was
like this is that and then when I felt
nothing and I heard nothing and then I
opened my eyes and I was there and I was
just long in there just bleeding and it
was like what are you gonna do you're
gonna sit here no you're gonna get up
and go home you know it's like go home
and somehow I found the result that get
to my feet walk home gather the things
they had scattered around because they
ripped my my pants I've been going going
through my stuff and went huh and up
until this point I had led a pretty
Cavalier life you know I was dating
girls that there was not it was very
unsubstantial relationship like it was
girls who I felt made me look good you
know
and actressy types and again you know I
thought living The Bachelor life or wow
I defined it and I could spend a lot of
money on toys and I'm writing a cartoon
show there everybody seems to like and
I'm you know kind of live in the geeks
dream and you know I went home and just
the the thing that hurt the most was
knowing there would be no one to say oh
my god
to the door there just be toys there
would be animation cells it'd be comic
books and there'd be mmm did you're a
writer so you get home yeah do you go to
the hospital or you're like like how
[ __ ] up were you well it was my nose
wasn't broken everything was really soft
and squishy feeling huh and I I felt
like I had just you know I had been
mangle that I didn't want to want to go
anywhere I didn't want to do anything I
just I wanted to drink and I took down a
bottle of rum and I great i drained it
and the worst thing you can do is
alcohol and heat after a trauma like
that and I but I and that was the only
thing I wanted to do was just you know
soothe myself the first thing first was
I drank then I called the police and I
said I had this assault and it happened
nearby and the police came and we went
back to the site and you know their
attitude was kind of like it wasn't I
would say it was cavalier but it was you
know we'll do what we can you know where
they say you should go to a hospital or
well yeah they did say you know you may
want to go to a hospital that looks
pretty bad and I said I'm just not a
port now I don't want to go I don't want
to sit in the emergency room I don't
want to see anybody I just I'll go
tomorrow I'll go see my doctor tomorrow
and I went home and I called a few
people and that's kind of outlined in
the book one friend of mine said you
know my boyfriend will drive me to the
hospital right away and it's like I've
never met your boyfriend before and this
is gonna be awkward does some dude I
don't even know I don't why I wanted to
spend like three hours in emergency and
us having to make small talk thank you
very much but I'll just tough it out so
I drank the rest of the bottle of Meyers
rum went up and sat in the bathtub and
went to bed and just fantasized like Oh
Batman where were you why don't you come
to my rescue you know that sort of thing
you know I think it's a logical thing
you know and even when the cop said you
write you write cartoons and I said yeah
which one Batman well you should have
been here at night running it's like
yeah oh man
the only writer in this town
earlier I'd taken this is in the book
I'd I had found like a the receipt from
dinner was still on the lawn they had
they taken it out of my pocket I said
you want to take that and desperate
Prince and the guy said that's okay
life's not like a TV yeah yeah yeah it's
like and I think they said look you know
it was bad what happened and we're sorry
but if we get more reports of this
happening in the neighborhood we'll give
you a call if we if we run anybody in
well we'll have you in but yeah
underneath the subtext was sort of like
you lived through this count your
blessings and go home and do what you
have to do go to the hospital and you
know you know I called them later and
called them a couple of times a couple
of days and they said your your case has
been assigned a number and if we hear
anything we'll call you and either the
guys it was an isolated incident or they
moved on or whatever there was no I
never heard anything more about it but
you had to deal with the after-effects
yeah so you carry that like luggage yeah
for for a long time yeah I mean you know
you start to question the idea it was I
think anybody's been the same situation
questioning the idea of justice you know
and how somebody can go to a fast-food
restaurant and got coffee sloshed on
them and get a minor burn and then sue
for millions and then I'm lying here
nearly you know beaten unconscious and
bleeding and and I uh you know I have to
pay for it you know and on my insurance
and I have to pay out of pocket for
whatever it takes and I'll never see
those guys again there there's nobody
saw anything and it was just it was just
one of those things I mean a lot of time
a weird image was going through my head
when they were doing the attack of being
like attacked by like a like a bear or
an animal
like an animal attack where something
just rushes you out of the bush and it
just rips you open and runs away and
there's nothing you can do about it I
don't necessarily mean to dehumanize
anybody it's just the sort of you know
result of the attack was so Swift and so
sudden and so isolated and the only
thing I could do was like being attacked
by a bear who's just waiting out I can't
fight back you know so just what would
the extent of the injuries my the as
part of my face was shattered the
zygomatic arch was broken my nose was
was fractured but it didn't need to be
reset it they kicked me very hard in the
thigh so there was a big bruise there he
one of the attackers was aiming for my
kneecap and I managed to move but I knew
that if he took out me and and just you
know kicks and Men and smashed us to the
face mostly you know all over the face
but mostly mostly when I fell on the
ground so at what point do you feel
ready to re-engage with the world after
that how long did you crawl into the
house or crawl into the room to be by
yourself before you were like all right
I'm ready to reengage well there was a
there was a moment you know like yeah
afterwards I thought okay life's going
on you know I'm gonna deal with this get
through it you know and so we know I the
next day I went to the doctor and he
said go to the hospital and I went to
see surgeon and he said we're gonna
schedule you for surgery because this
whole side of your face is broken in a
day so you know sort of like or a day
and a half so basically figure you know
get ready to come in day after tomorrow
so and I said okay I'm getting you know
I'll deal with him I'll go to work so I
you know put on a pair of sunglasses
went to work and I thought okay business
is usual and I started dealing with it
and then I went to the hospital had the
surgery done and after that I I
retreated you know it was like I
I I want to take a few steps back from
this I'm not as brave and as ballsy as I
thought I want to stay home and I want
to go into work I don't want to talk to
people I don't want to see people I just
want to stay home I want to stay where
it's comfy you want to stay inside where
it's safe it's safe you know and so it
was a process of you know trying to get
myself out of that and you know and we
were in the middle of writing the mask
of the phantasm movie and that's when
this happen yeah yeah and and Alan
Burnett call it we kept calling me and
said you know you're gonna you want me
to give your scenes to somebody else you
want off the project and it's like oh
yeah I think I do because I don't want
to character doesn't make any sense to
me anymore I mean you know he just sort
of and then why is this stuff happen I I
kind of lost I felt like I lost the
ability to write this stuff and
gradually my life turned around think
we're gonna keep cooking
thank God Alan you know held my scenes
for me he was a very good friend through
for me throughout this and very
supportive and yet it was sort of I
reached this juncture when I realized
okay your life is gonna go one or two
ways you're really gonna stay here or
are you gonna get out there again and
you have to you know and I don't think
I'm gonna be happy staying here and I
and the more I dwelled in my head the
more the more I am you know that voice
of stay here stay where it's safe and
the more I would get out the more I
talked to people the more it would be
like outsides better and I would talk to
people who were starting to enjoy the
show and I would talk to people who
would enjoy cartoons and and some of the
stuff that I had written and even if it
was just a chance and occurrence you
know it would be like you know that
things were going okay before then
you know there was a lot of my own
hubris that got me into this situation
but maybe I can kind of take control of
my life again and go back out among
people again and I don't have to look
toward you know beyond myself to make
myself happy you know that's gonna come
from inside so life sort of brought you
back to life yeah yeah you know there
were accounts with other people who do I
talk to who just said you know you know
one one fellow in particular said my
wife's really sick can we watch cartoons
it's the only thing that makes life good
so it's like well if I could be a part
of that I don't want to walk wait that's
[ __ ] pop I mean come on dude like
right then and there you're impacting
somebody's life you write the stuff
office oh god it's frivolity but it's
look that makes all the [ __ ]
difference to them yeah yeah so that
brings you better then that makes you go
like you know what [ __ ] I'm going
back in I'm gonna dive back into life
how long do you think you were nervous
scared frightened before you were like
alright I'm ready to take life on again
well you know I think the core of it was
about two or three months you know we're
just sitting at home and very very
rarely did I go into work worth it was
for an hour or two and I would call in
sick a lot of times because I just
didn't wasn't up for dealing with it and
and and you know I would come back and
and kind of question what's the point of
this I'm just doing it by myself
it doesn't matter to anybody and who
cares really and and it just had to
matter to me and so through talking to
other people and through the support of
some very good people you know friends
to family members so I I kind of saw me
what they smell nice
well we all see everything and you dude
you're a [ __ ] hero though and you're
my especially with this story did you
might hear like I said it when you told
me the story
I'm antenna now I would have been
destroyed that would have been it for me
man that would have taken me out of the
game he was going along in your life a
certain path and you think your biggest
problems or some anonymous [ __ ] on
the internet going what you're sucking
your job like that's a real thing
on our street and suddenly like [ __ ]
he punches you in the face until you
think like it's over yeah you found a
way to kind of put it all back together
go back out man that's heroic and stuff
when does this come into play that comes
into play
June 21st that's when it comes out and
it will be available in online and but
when did I'm sorry no well that's good
to know but when did you when was the
moment where how long was it between the
incident and there's got to be like Oh
20 years yeah
23 years 23 an incident moment 23 years
it was it was late
late January 2000
I mean 1993 and and it was like almost
no 26 27th of that month like that was a
night that was out as cold walking home
and and and it was you know so it's been
a long time and and I don't think I
could have told the story back then you
know I would have been a different story
it would have been a story where I don't
think I would have learned as much and I
wouldn't have experienced as much I
could have told that five or ten years
but I it's like the time you know the
hurt went away the the perspective
changed my life changed in a lot of ways
I began looking at myself and the people
around me a little more different there
was a whole thing of forgiveness to work
through both for myself for the
attackers for letting it go for the idea
that for whatever reason they did it for
it whoever they are
I just hope their life it is better they
just don't do stuff like this brother
owns me when was the first time you were
able to go back to writing Batman mm it
was about a month or two after that I
mean you know we were really needed to
get the phantasm script underway and
I've been delaying a lot of it
and and the other writers were running
you know stuff that I should have been
writing and and it was like well you
know it's in the book one night I was
out and the guy was talking about how
much cartoons meant to him and his wife
maybe you shouldn't hang up on it so and
so I was like within the night or two of
that it was I actually was watching one
of the old show and one of the episodes
I'm watching it on VHS and I kinda used
to do this [ __ ] you know I'm sitting
there I'm an old Apple computer and
trying to think like okay Joker talks
like that and I realize like I hadn't
really forgotten that I just didn't want
to it was almost like embracing it was
sort of bringing back an element of the
pain the the idea that okay you know the
fantasy of it and I had to delve back
into the fantasy of okay I'm you know
Batman's not gonna make you know my life
any better in a real way but maybe I can
at least write a good Batman story again
so that you know got me back into it and
also just did the character did writing
the character did your Batman change
after this like how does because every
every writer who takes on the character
is writing a slightly different Batman
yeah so like how does the Batman that
you write post that event different from
the one you wrote pre that if I had in a
way he became a little more human I
think he became a little more like yeah
and still got beat people up and
everything but he might in my head he
was a little more circumspect about it
maybe a little more like
there are people I'm beating up and you
know maybe just doing the Frank Miller
thing of smashing somebody's head
through a glass window it's cool and
visceral but maybe once the guy stops
moving that's the time to time up and
they're like that first night trying to
go to sleep yeah if he just swung down
and smashed and kicked them out of their
car cuz I was walking home there ething
tried to run me down their car they we
saw him again oh yeah yeah once I got
out I was walking home and and I was
trying to stay in the light I was
crossing the street and this car just
shot down the road and it was the two
guys and they had getting in their car
and they were driving off and they saw
me and they they like pop the horn skin
of the brakes and shouted all sorts of
lovely things out of the window and
flipped me off and laughed and
everything so in the book you imagine
Batman swinging down yeah and just
smashing into the front of the car and
tossing them out but the reason we
imagine [ __ ] like yeah is because
someone like you imagines it for us
first you know see I'm like the reason
so many of us have Batman you know
anti-crime or [ __ ] saving fantasies
yeah or because we've seen it at play in
the cartoon and game in a comic book or
sound like that so there is that feeling
of like in a just world yes some dude in
a costume yeah I would do right by me
yeah but that's not really the but then
you hear stories like the Dean trip who
wrote that book something terrible which
is all about yeah I mean which is
beautiful but it's about Batman actually
saving him from dealing with with just a
tragedy of childhood abuse yeah it's
very real for him yeah in a way that you
know it is not real for other people
because other people don't have to live
through it right so much of that is part
of the work that you do is helping other
people on a Batman you know get over any
number of just devastating traumas sure
sure and I
luckily Batman seemingly helped you yes
he does in the same way well he's uh he
became that stern voice I had to hearing
you know of somebody who read the book
said you know Becca's not very nice to
you on the book it's like no she
shouldn't be he should be like you know
dad he should be like a drill sergeant
he should be like it's not a question of
being nice it's like get off your ass
you know go off and do something you
don't like your life do something about
it and to be very ship it nicer you've
could put some of the best he's ever
spoken into his mouth yeah well he'll
never admit it I mean it's gotta be a
hard-ass it's gotta be Batman now the
Joker on the other hand wants to be your
pal
he's like buddy boy take it easy you
know sit down take a load off you don't
have to work today and that's the worst
thing you want you know that's the most
easy thing to listen to but it's the
last thing you should be doing but so
really is angel and W know Batman is
like Grimm get up you know you're you do
something with your life and the Joker
is like go to three if you will and
let's throw up some of the graphics that
we've got from inside the book these are
some sketches that the great eduardo
visit edwards oh yeah he is phenomenal
he did he did 101 oh yeah oh yeah and he
did something else to the a lot of
things yeah there was another always
work is he working on the dark night
book I think he's one of the artists
yeah yeah he's doing he's doing that
right now and it was it was a real
change of pace room because it's like a
real world story so a lot of stuff he's
drawing is not as visceral as 100
bullets it's like me you know work or
you know sit around a conference table
or anything but he brought it all to
desks yeah he did you at a desk pretty
well
like having to draw a guy writing yeah
it's pretty damn awesome yeah yeah very
active have fled that back up I'm sorry
we were all looking away so there's no
his version of the penguin that's really
great it was cool it was beak it's like
it's a very unique version but it does
read as penguin and penguins in the
story is the guy who you know kind of
the Joker who's like you know take it
easy
have another drink you know I so the
villains kind of let you wallow in like
your self-pity yes and Batman's like
good up yeah yeah I mean the penguin is
like an and joker like indulgence two
faces like this is okay this happen to
you for a reason on reason is inside
you're kind of an ugly dude and you've
made some really bad choices and you go
live again go live this is good and and
poison ivy is there to remind me of
every failure I've ever had in dating
and trying to you know be something I'm
not
- two girls who I want to see me a
certain way so it's like they are there
to strip away you know elements of this
veneer that I I put up for myself at the
time you know and goddamn it gets in
there some way only you could get away
with this - yeah and I'm saying like
aside from the incident that incites it
you put enough time in with the
character in the world where you know
even if people like well I don't want to
mix my Batman with the real world it's
you know you get the past because it's
like hey this guy's family yeah he's so
much family creative family for the
family in the family like Harley Quinn
so if that gives you the license to do
it and you jammed it man it's phenomenal
let's look at your works diverse yeah
just you know those characters better
than most people do so you know this
sort of the Greek archetypes that all of
these cameras yeah and this Horace this
sort of swirling around you just when
you hear and pulling you there and
pushing you this way if I was really
inspired by you know Greek drama Greek
chorus and things like that or you know
we're outside voices are working inside
the the main character's head even to
the point of something contemporary like
Woody Allen's play it again Sam learn
he's going through a divorce and the
ghost of Bogart is over his shoulders
because they're you know talking to him
and things like that
it's where the line between reality and
fantasy melts and as a kid who grew up
with cartoons and who could uh you know
it would zone out in church and Looney
Tunes would play in front of my head
like that and it was like a defense
mechanism you know use you know your you
use your imagination your no imagination
and everything and and you you you find
a lot of comfort there so in and with
these characters that I've worked with
and I know you know so they were
extensions of fears and demons and hopes
let's look at throw up the works
workplace photos the workspace now this
is kind of interesting man walk us
through this well this is uh this is at
my house in my writers room I have a I
have a big you know these wooden doors
there off to one side and as I was
writing the story I would create these
collages of certain images that I was
trying to you know evoke or emotions and
I would take images from the comics or
from my childhood or from just any
anyplace comic books and I would kind of
juxtapose them on the on the computer so
they all meant different things so
there's a shot there of to face and and
the doctor doing a very similar
operation of the one I had about the
idea of cutting back part of my face and
everything so to face was a very you
know a vivid image for that there for a
while I was thinking I'm gonna go off
and buy a gun so you know hey kids
really let's go buy a gun no go back to
us yeah there was a moment where you're
like I should get a gun oh yeah yeah and
and it was and there least Batman thing
you could ever think I know I know but
there's a reason why I did there was a
reason why I didn't so and that's part
of the stories but that's part of the
story as well that is like what's
beautiful about that as some writers
will do good writers will do note cards
and paste them up and stuff that's an
even more graphically beautiful version
of
this is where my story is gonna go right
you're laying it out there for yourself
so that when you're right you're just
looking up there and pulling memories
lots and not everything made it in there
but you know I think I would find a shot
of the Riddler and I would go like the
question isn't why this happened it's
who cares you know and you know who
really gives a [ __ ] about your little
problems or Mr Freeze being very cold
and saying [ __ ] happens get over it you
know it's so smart and like I mean on
one level I wanted to be like I'm so
[ __ ] jealous but you had to go
through hell it's such an insanely good
idea to kind of psychoanalyze oneself
yeah I'm using the Batman family well
there's that viven and there's some
iconic they each represent anything so
they each represent a different thing
people have said why is Harley Quinn not
in the book it's like she represents
happiness an excellent point man god
damn it Paul you've never stopped
writing always a beautiful writer man
like if you've never seen and who the
[ __ ] has if you're watching the show
clearly you've seen the mr. Frese
episode of Kult with a heart of ice you
know Batman I made series season 1 yeah
I remember watching the [ __ ] game
right yeah go a three-shot is crazy
manly like I remember watch I was
working a quick stop that is in close
and I taped it and I remember like I
called Walter Flannigan who's on comic
book man yeah to just feel like did you
just watch because that was when they
ran in the afternoon did you just watch
bamas like yes I was like have they ever
done that Mr Freeze story anywhere he
goes no and I've been reading comics for
25 years
I was like that is astounding they
transcended the genre like you turn that
character from something hokey and
stupid
George Sanders going speaking a bad
pitch jurema German accent too like this
really sad story of a broken love and
you know world giving on the way
happenstance like a really tragic
villain yeah as opposed to just like God
likes things cold yeah he likes it
chilly yeah but but that's you all over
man you find a way to do the human the
humane even in a world of characters
that are [ __ ] monsters and cartoons
these characters are two-dimensional
yeah in the hands of most people but
like when I think of the great Batman
writers you are [ __ ] up there it's
you and not you are [ __ ] up there you
are
shoulder-to-shoulder with with the bigs
with the legends because again you
didn't just come in and play with their
toys you came in made their toys better
by the time you left they have better
and more toys to play with
yeah and they had more fun even with you
or without you well you know Batman is
is it such a rich world and the
characters are so iconic and they're so
evocative of different things you know
Catwoman is always right at least I
always think of her as like the
forbidden love you know I I go that far
to be with her I lose everything if I
kill the Joker I become him if I you
know I'm like two-faced and I've got two
identities and I and and how am i
different from him and you know all
these things that are that they're kind
of bring out extensions of Batman's soul
or his personality they become more than
the character is they become like ideas
so that's what I was tapping into with
these guys's like what are what's the
character about this has a metric
fuckton of soul and most badass stories
you read you enjoy better beat him up
fantasies and stuff this goes deep this
runs really
if there was and one day there will be
because it looks like you know
everything's coming up genre geek nerd
whatever you want to call it these days
yeah
if there was a Mount Rushmore as we see
in our logo for Batman riders your face
is on it dude your face god be on you
brought something to it no I'm saying
walk your the franchise well I guess I
take I would take a map I gotta have it
you know I feel about you in your word
it's amazing but this is that I'm so
proud of you for doing this because I
know this was hard well thank you for
first you know kickin it awake in my
head again you know without without you
without that talk we had it would have
just sort of been an unpleasant memory
so I remember we first day you were like
I'm working on that as a story I'm gonna
do it as a book and I was like that's
genius dude that's how it like you
altima like you put your life back
together and move down this is 22 years
ago whatever but this is how this is the
final step you know and I'm saying like
now it's it's something you've taken
your pain turning into something useful
for yourself and other people yeah yeah
you know somebody's gonna read that and
go like okay if the slot can get through
it I can I can you know that sort of
thing you know no sloppy shot yeah I
know
oh gee Batman writer write why do we
fall down master Bruce so we can get
back up again there you go there you go
there you go I saw that wasn't one of
them Avengers movies yeah
Paul we love you for everything you've
done
we love in this included is yet another
the huge plaudits put up on the many
plotted at wall of Paul Dini dude you
like you keep doing it like some people
just start phoning in I'm phoning it in
right my career my inseam I'll get you
dude you're doing this you know I'm
saying well played well thank you my
brother
I really owe you more than I could say
not at all me kidding me I owe you my
kids we're gonna call her Batman Smith
thank God for Harley Quinn I'm just glad
she didn't show up in my house around
age 9 you know with that baseball bat
you got her going Paul can you come out
and they're gonna talk to you from
sports you know when she was a kid I
don't we didn't know if she'd ever like
her name and that she like loves it oh
yeah it was positioned well like it's a
Harley Quinn world nice and the people
who like oh when she was little everyone
always I'd be like what's her name big
Harley I feel like no you rock yeah like
now but nowadays you've got like what's
her name like Harley like oh can we
pursue that squad oh my God we're in
that world I mean I've seen you know
Harley is getting to be a more and more
common name for girls and was almost
like you know it probably was but this
is sort of it puts it out there like
before James Barry wrote Peter Pan
nobody named a kid Wendy and then
suddenly it just it just sort of took
off you know there's going to be a wave
of children born like next July yeah
yes do then you finally taken that name
and probably given it a little license
plate at Disneyworld
oh wow man that kid's name is about to
be mainstream thanks to those movies
Harley we're now going to be able to
find on a coffee cup that's right okay
I'm a small first of all problem for a
guy with a kid named Harley it's a big
deal in my world there it is folks the
book again is called Dark Knight a true
Batman story written by the one the only
Paul Dini standing right over there is
an absolute legend thank you for coming
in sir thank you go get the book comes
out dear at June 21st June 21 hardcover
softcover her cover first yep we got was
about galleys there it is man go out get
the book when it's out folks or right
until that comes out and go patronize
any Baldy anything throw a rock you will
hit something that he's been involved
let's go watch that first season a
batmanning yeah it's gonna feel do and
you do thanks for hanging out sir that's
all the time we got here in the fat cave
this week man thanks for hanging out
I've been Kevin Smith I've been mark
barnard me and I've been happy to be
here soon in next time same bat time
same bat Channel YouTube that come back
to us Kevin Smith
man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder